hello everybody I hope you are good
what's going on with Bitcoin
well I think we have Bitcoin under
control here because we are
understanding the moves okay so let me
go through what is happening
um remember the from the first video I
think it was around here on Monday yeah
it was on Monday
and we saw the Bitcoin came to 29 200
but we knew that there was a lot of
liquidations at this level at 29 100 and
Bitcoin went High just to come back
lower again because in this little
bounds people were expecting that this
was the bottom so that they were going
to open long positions and therefore
they were gonna set the stop losses and
liquidations below
the previous support which is 29 100
fine Asia went low stop wound to this
area 29 100 all the liquidation is taken
and then it reverses okay then at this
moment yesterday it was during the
London session we were talking about the
potential trading session pattern which
is
Asia pumps or dumps then London might
hold and then New York my reverse
or we also talk about the possibility
that if London didn't hold then they
were going to attack this liquidity pool
over here fine that's what happened
Bitcoin just went up during the London
season you can see here
that's a 11 UTC UTC time in the London
session goes up to this liquidity pool
ranges potential M formation here
okay and then it comes back down again
where to
to the ACM pump
okay look at this
this is on Tuesday
1 am UTC time that's when Asia opens the
session
and they just came back lower this is
what I told you guys I didn't like this
pump don't trust Asian pumps okay I've
been telling you this for months years
after how long just on Tuesday symptoms
because they tend to get retrace
um I've told you specifically it usually
happens
either in the next New York session or
in the next Asian session and it
happened in the next Asian session this
time okay so
that's something that we considered
now let's see what it might be happening
well the first thing that comes to my
mind is the possibility of the trading
systems pattern playing out so I'm gonna
draw this scenario again okay
um let me draw faster Asian session
here it is
from one to eight
and then the London session the one we
are currently on
till two
and the New York session okay let me go
to the 30 minutes time frame so we can
see it more clear
I made this look nicer for you guys now
you can see Asia doomed we might be
looking for London to hold let's see
what's going on there and then if London
holds we could see New York reversible
we are not biased Traders so
we have invalidations during validation
basically this box is the box I'm gonna
draw for the London session if it starts
retracing this large scandal
okay if we do something like this during
the London session
I'm not gonna like that why because then
in the New York session if I'm looking
for a long
there is not much room to take here okay
so
essentially I would only trade along in
the New York session if I see something
like this I want to see London playing
in this area over here then you can see
in this area that there are quite a lot
of weeks to the downside
which means that the retail Trader
thinks that this is support So at the
start of the New York session I would
love to see a little stop point over
here and a reversal to retrace this
candle
over here okay so that's one scenario
I'm gonna be looking for today well
obviously only if London States in this
box
in the other hand if you start seeing
Bitcoin going lower how low it can go
what's the next Zone let's go to the
Daily time frame here you're gonna be
able to see it very clearly well sorry
four hours time frame
okay this is a song that we've been
talking about and this this previous
resistance that should be tested as
support so if we draw a line over here
that's a 28 720.
that's a potential support so
there is nothing
I mean I think
it's very likely that sooner or later
Bitcoin comes to this area Okay so but
we're gonna go Day by Day level by level
well when I first look at these
potential long in the New York session
if London holds that box if not we're
gonna look for this area getting hit
okay also if you go to the dollar Index
let's go Abdullah is doing you can see
that dollar is bouncing this could
explain that awful Campbell for Bitcoin
okay but you can see that it still
hasn't come to these levels
so of course this is still a lot of room
for Bitcoin to go lower
stay alert
okay
because it's possible
the Bitcoin what is my binance chart
that I've seen in there
because it's possible that Bitcoin
comes even lower and what I'm trying to
say is that tone plays your lungs
automatically in this song without
looking at the chart because
it might not be tested as support I
might just continue going lower or
renting this Zone then from here they're
already 1K down in bitcoin price okay
so be very very cautious here then what
will be the next support
we've been talking about it in the
Sunday update on Twitter but you have
this level over here
let me draw for you
that one there high time frame price
resistance you can see
from here there was a sell-off
and then it comes back again and we see
another cell of okay so has this area
been tested as support
I wouldn't say so it hasn't been tested
that support so
what is stopping us from thinking that
Bitcoin could be doing something like
this
nothing
so please be very careful with your
trades and trade level by level within
validation and without any bias
I like to say this because I know you're
thinking Bitcoin is going down what can
I open along for a reversal well the
first thing is that you shouldn't be
trying to catch a fallen knife
that's what I'm trying to say because
yes there is a there is more liquidity
to the upside too okay
but we're gonna go level by level day by
day without any biased and using or
logic
so thank you so much for watching I
don't want to bore you anymore with my
speeches
thank you for watching guys
and I see you soon